♪ Uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Perspective is the game ♪
♪ I guarantee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head down ♪
♪ Do the work and everything will change ♪
♪ Tip with me ♪
♪ Help the fields, yeah
that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient hella
tricky if I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Preachin' positivity ♪
- Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
It is Tuesday, May something. (laughs)
May 19th.
Happy birthday to anybody
that was born on this day.
I'm in a good vibe.
I'm outside.
I'm trying to mix it up.
Get that lighting right
for everybody out here.
Just wanna give a big shout out,
Coach Dill's always in the building,
my guy for a decade at this point.
Good to see you behind the
lens really appreciate you.
I love the new intro as well.
That's not, I really like that new intro.
Can you play it one
more time for the kids?
- Sure.
- Let's just do it.
♪ Start of my life was kind of rough ♪
♪ I had an uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Perspective is the game ♪
♪ I guarantee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head down ♪
♪ Do the work and everything will change ♪
♪ Tip with me ♪
♪ Help the fields, yeah
that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient hella
tricky if I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Preachin' positivity ♪
- I like positivity.
Like that shit in the end gets me going.
(Dustin chuckling)
How are you, Dustin?
- Good.
- All well?
- Yeah, I woke up like
every hour, last night, but.
- Too excited for Tea with GaryVee,
the 15 minute earlier slot?
- I think I was anxious about it.
it's like a franchise for you.
I think I kept on thinking is,
do I need to wake up right now?
- Like wake up early.
- Yeah.
- It was only 15 minutes, Dustin.
- I know, I'm crazy.
- Let's get into the show.
- Whoa, this is crazy.
How are you?
- I'm well.
- Wow.
First of all,
I just wanna say that,
because my Instagram got
deleted at some point
because I was promoting my music
and you were mentioning TikTok.
And when you mentioned TikTok,
I just went all in
and after posting 702 times,
my video went viral with 15 million
and that literally started the process
of changing my life.
And I just wanna thank you for that.
- That's amazing.
- It really means a lot.
- So, thank you, thank you.
So to give a little bit of context...
- What's your name?
- Tiagz.
My artist name is Tiagz
and my name is Tiago.
- Tiago, real pleasure.
Go ahead.
- Real pleasure.
So, I was born in Ottawa, Canada,
and I live my nine years
here and then I moved
to Belgium and in Belgium
I lived nine years there
and for me, my passion
was really like dance.
So that was like my thing.
And after that we moved back to Venezuela.
'Cause my dad's job was
finished in Venezuela,
lived six months and really there,
I started, like I was by myself
and I really had to practice on myself,
and just practice dance because
I was very entitled back
in Belgium 'cause I had
just had everything, right.
So I started working, working.
- Hard to be hungry when you're fed.
- Exactly, exactly. (chuckles)
So, I pass that time in
Venezuela, just training dance.
And then from there the
situation was very difficult.
So we moved back to Ottawa, Canada,
which I am now.
And that's when I discovered
music and I was like,
yo, I didn't understand
because a lot of artists were more known
and at that time I was actually
listening to Tai Lopez.
And when I came to your content at first,
I was like, wait, no, this is too,
like, it was too aggressive.
Like a lot of people say
that it just starts aggressive.
And after that I watched it again
and you were talking about music
and I would relate the
music with my dancing
and then I would just listen
and listen and listen.
And really you were like that only voice
that really helped me when everybody
was just, like telling me otherwise
like, oh you gotta do it this way.
You gotta do it this way.
But then I just kept,
I kept listening,
I went to have a part-time job
just cleaning, mopping the
floor, cleaning the toilet,
just like hustling, hustling.
- I love that humility.
- Thank you, thank you.
And after that, yeah,
I started posting my memes on Instagram,
but the community
guidelines, they said, no,
we're gonna do your account.
Like this is not possible.
I was at 12,000 followers
and then everything just vanished.
And like I said,
you were saying, yo,
TikTok, TikTok, TikTok.
And I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna take my chance.
Went on TikTok, post 702
times, and everything.
And yeah, just tried everything.
And I was really,
I was really pushing the music.
I was just dropping tracks
and getting no tracks,
dropping tracks, getting no tractions.
And as soon as,
I had that moment of TikTok,
I was like, wow, this works.
So there was this meme going on on TikTok,
like a trending thing.
And I used it and I
incorporated it in my music,
and as soon as I did that,
people loved it.
The video on YouTube got a million views,
it went viral on TikTok.
And after that I was
like, wow, this works.
I'm gonna' continue doing.
'Cause you really preach,
like, keep doing what works.
And I remember at that
time I was this close
to not posting it,
but I just listened to
a video of your saying,
be in the yes business, just do it.
So I was like, you know
what, I'm just gonna post it
and see what happens.
And that was literally
the process of changing.
And then, I did the same thing for,
I don't know if you've
heard My Heart Went Oops.
- Yup.
- Well, I did the same thing without one,
use the sound on TikTok
that I was like super happy.
I was like, yes.
And I did the same thing
with, They Call Me Tiago.
It blew up on sake talk and
then another one just go up
on TikTok and I just want to really, yeah.
And I just really want to thank you
because you were really that only voice
that was helping me going through this
and the TikTok game is really real.
So thank you.
- You're welcome, brother.
Is there anything I can help you with now?
- Yes, so I wanted to ask you,
so I stayed with the me you say
You say post music consistently
just drop music like
quantity versus quality.
And I've been doing that for a while,
but now I'm signing--
- Not bad quality.
Okay.
That's the part that I think a lot
of people get a little bit confused
about my message I'm in the business
of quality and quantity.
Quantity is not subjective.
Quality is you almost talked yourself out
of posting the posts
that changed your life
because you were judging the quality,
let the world judge
the quality, so people,
people think it's an or game
and I think it's an and game.
Like to me, it's, it's
not, it's not, quality,
quantity over quality.
It's quantity is black and white
and quality is subjective.
- Of course.
- And so that's a big deal for me.
And it's real.
- It's super real.
It's how the whole world's always worked
and quality comes out
of your ability period.
Whether, if you've got it,
it's gonna be quality.
Some things are gonna hit the market more.
I say 48 things over and over.
I say them 570,000 different ways.
And eventually like one
hits that person, right?
Like maybe if I said be
in the yes business like that time,
thank God it hit you.
And it worked.
But I say,
go and do all the time.
It was just that,
I remember that, that thought,
I mean, I thought about something
the other day about like,
what's my humanity footprint.
Then think about this term in my head.
Like, what's my humanity footprint.
Meaning like we talk about
like our carbon footprint
and like all these other footprints
that I'm like, yo, what's
my humanity footprint.
Like what am I doing every day?
That's that's making
an impact on humanity.
Here's, a kid from Venezuela,
Ottawa, Europe who, just listened.
It taught him the humility to go
and mop floors.
It gave him the courage and the ability
to put out 702 pieces of content.
What happened and that's leaving,
that's leaving a legacy,
So don't get it twisted my guy,
and this is not,
quantity over quality.
This is quantity is black
and white and quality
is a hundred percent
subjective by the market.
Not by you or the label for your homie
or your uncle or me.
- Facts.
Yeah, facts, it's so true.
And I also wanted to
ask can content ever hurt a person,
like let's say I drop tracks,
but then there's one track
that does not do well.
Can it hurt the artist
or the constant creative.
- The Beatles have bad songs.
- Yeah, facts.
I see, listen to that the other day.
- What I mean?
Like I want to say bad songs.
It means not popular, but like,
if it's coming from your soul
and you're writing it or
you're interpreting it
or you're composing it,
it's not bad.
It just might not be popular.
- Sure.
- No, I don't think so.
I think the only thing that,
I think the only thing
that can hurt someone
is when they come with bad intent.
- Okay, nice.
That's really true.
And all, I'm sorry to keep you here, but.
- That's all right, go ahead.
- I was just very excited.
And what else should I
be doing as an artist?
Like I dropped the music,
I'm also doing Q and A's,
you say a lot of watch what I do know.
What's what I say.
So I've been trying to--
- What I'd probably do right now.
How many followers do you have?
- I'm at 1.9 million.
- I think you used the clout of TikTok
and you reach out to,
I would make a list of the 50
to 500 favorite producers
or artists you have.
And I would DM them on
Instagram and say, Hey,
first you do the homework.
Hey, I've noticed that you haven't
gone serious on TikTok yet.
It's really pop for me.
Why don't we collab on TikTok,
I can give you a jump off point.
And I actually think there's a lot
of big artists who want that.
- True.
- So I think what that
does then is allows you
to actually collaborate
and make a joint song
with fucking Future,
with fucking Juul, with Aerosmith.
Like I would just reach
out to like fucking 50
to a hundred dream people,
DM them on Instagram
and be like, yo, I'm winning on the Tok,
you need to as well, you
want to do something.
One of them is gonna say yes.
- True.
That's a fact.
And my last question is,
if in the future after quarantine,
like if we could,
maybe meet up and just chat
if you're open.
- I'm in.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- Peace, bro.
- All right, thank you.
Thank you.
- Alright, where's Sarah, Dustin?
You fucking threw me for a loop.
That dude was fucking Epic.
- She's next.
Everyone keeps yelling at me.
- Well they're right, you fucked up.
Finally.
- Hi man.
- Hi man. (laughs)
How are you Sarah?
- I'm really good.
How are you?
- I'm super well,
I'm so sorry for how awful
of a human being Dustin was yesterday.
- Oh, it's totally fine.
I was totally shitting my
pants yesterday to get on.
And so it gave me a chance to
calm myself down for today.
Absolutely.
- How are you?
- I'm really good actually, surprisingly,
this entire experience being at home
and not physically being at my job
has actually gotten me to a place
where I'm better at my job now.
- I love that.
- It's exposed a lot of things
about people, I think in
general and in my case,
it's exposed that I'm
good at communicating
through these types of
mediums, especially writing,
not so much video,
I'm terrified of doing this right now.
- You're doing good.
- So I'm killing it at work,
which is absolutely amazing.
Bu I feel guilty saying
that because people
are obviously going through
some really serious stuff
and I work in healthcare.
So I see it every day,
but I'm on the admin side.
So I kind of don't get
that direct contact,
but it can be overwhelming.
It's stressful.
But apparently those are the
situations that I thrive in.
And I didn't know that.
So I learned that.
- I'm proud of you.
That's a really nice trait.
- It's good to learn those
things about yourself.
I think.
- I agree, I agree.
It's why I want children to be
in far more diverse
and adverse situations.
- Yeah, I have three kids and they are--
- Some dads just run the
school and fight teachers
and principals and coaches,
and then fucking fighting for their kids.
And then our kids are 22
and they don't have fight.
- I completely agree with you.
We have kids in special
education right now doing that.
And they're thriving right now.
Work like go doing school
the way they're doing it.
'Cause they just don't
have that distraction.
They don't have that negative energy
that they might get in
school and they're kind
of figuring it out on their own
and they're doing great.
- I really, really, really,
I also it's to your point,
it's so hard to talk about
the positives during COVID
because of how much sadness is happening,
but there are enormous amounts
of incredible things going on
in the world and I hope people see them.
So I'm glad you're here, Sarah.
What can I answer for you?
- So I had two questions,
and hopefully they're pretty short.
One's kind of selfish and one's more
about you and, general.
So I've been at the same
company for almost 10 years,
right out of college,
kind of fell into it.
But it grew a passion for healthcare.
Helping people, I'm not direct healthcare,
it's not my game.
I'm more on the admin
side, operations, projects,
all this stuff.
I'm a sole contributor.
I don't manage people,
I manage things.
And over that time,
I've really kind of
honed what I'm good at.
And ever since starting
to watch you probably,
I think it's about four years now.
I want to say the self-awareness
piece was huge for me
and I really spent a lot
of time focusing on that
and I realized what I'm good
at, what I'm not good at
and what I want and what I don't want,
but I'm worried that I know this, but I'm,
I've been at the same place for so long
that I'm potentially being
pigeonholed somewhere
that I don't necessarily want to be.
- Well, of course you're
being pigeonholed.
Everyone does.
And that's okay.
That's just normal human behavior
in structured environments,
team environments working.
- Yeah.
So I guess my question is,
is there a way to,
kind of undo some of
that after you've been
somewhere for so long?
And if so, what are your thoughts on that?
- It's just candorous
conversation and communication
to the decision makers.
It is literally going up the ranks of like
whoever has leverage, bosses
partners, bosses bosses,
and just flat out
communicating your truth.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- There's been people in my
career that I've pigeonholed
that have come into my
office and said, I'm this.
And I'm like, cool show me.
And some of them have thrived
and others have flopped.
And then there's other people
that have come to other bosses
and managers and they yes them to death
and never did anything.
And then the Sarah's
of the world leave after another year.
There's other people
that have gone to bosses
and managers communicated it
and the person did nothing about it.
And then the Sarahs of
the world sat and dwelled
about it and sat there
for another 15 years being pigeonholed.
That's what's cool about life.
You're in control.
You go and have the talk
and then you play the hand that's dealt
to you after they adjust
to it one way or the other.
- Yeah.
Unfortunately for me,
I was two weeks away from having
that kind of conversation.
And now--
- No, I actually, I
actually think listening
to your story lucky for you
that two weeks before you were going
to have the conversation,
a global event happened
that even showed your skills even more,
which probably is gonna give you
even more leverage going
into that conversation.
- I'm hoping that you're right.
And I will definitely take
that into consideration.
I mean, do you think it's
appropriate to approach this in
this situation like
right now or do I wait?
- I think it comes down to the judge.
You need to of who you're
going to this with.
- Right.
- And I think it depends
on her or his demeanor,
- Fair enough.
- I think timing matters.
I think this can be an incredible time
and I think this could
be an all time bad time.
I think there's, I err
on the side of continue
to build leverage if you're
shining so much right now.
- Sure.
- Especially as we're
theoretically we're in some
sort of place that we're gonna be out
of this at some point,
So I don't know.
I think there is no,
without knowing who the judge of this is,
it's why I love marketing to the world,
not to an individual when
you're at the mercy of a human,
you're just gonna have,
a very subjective kind of moment, but,
I think, I think either
way it's gonna play out,
one way or another, like,
if you've got a progressive
open-minded empathetic,
boss or leader or manager,
however this is structured.
It probably plays out
well at any scenario,
if you've got a little bit of a weaker,
insecure political one,
then I do think the
timing may play a factor.
- Yeah and I think that's generally,
I'm a bit worried about that.
I work for a very small company.
I have a very empathetic boss,
but the power does not
lie necessarily with her.
It lies above her.
And so regardless of my
conversation with her,
it's gonna be escalated.
So it's really just,
I have to pander to a number of people,
not just one obviously.
- Listen, you have all
those conversations.
- Yeah.
- I think you're mentally prepared
to make a move regardless.
I think you're in a win-win spot.
- That's a long time coming.
So I appreciate the advice.
I have a second question for you.
This is more about you,
so I'm hoping you can answer.
So we kind of started
the conversation about,
how this entire time has
exposed weaknesses, strengths,
whatever from people.
So what would you say is exposed about you
and will it shape anything you're gonna do
in the future that you
wouldn't have thought
you would have done?
- My biggest strength,
thank you.
My biggest strength is interpersonal
relationships and being
in the same room with somebody
and feeling the energy
on some like foofy shit
that helps me navigate decision-making.
The thing this is exposed
is that I can scale
that through video conferencing.
And that blows my mind.
- Yeah.
- And so it's gonna
change a ton of things.
I'll probably get to travel 25 to 40% less
'cause I don't need to go
to Chicago for this meeting
where I have to feel it.
- Right.
- It's going to allow me to not stress
about missing my kids' things
in the middle of the day,
when I'm rushing out the
office to go to the thing.
Now I can leave two hours earlier
and do video conference at the Starbucks
or the apartment close by.
it's led to a lot
of happiness for me around,
around the balance of travel and work,
the balance of,
non-work events and work events.
It's allowed me,
it's exposed how advanced
communication has gotten
on video conferencing platforms.
And I'm gonna take advantage of that.
I'm gonna work from home probably
once a week now,
because I feel like I am,
it's exposed that I
concentrate more in my meetings
on video conference
than I do in my office.
So, and then,
and then the thing I,
I've had the luxury of
navigating my family business
as a 26 year old,
25 year old through 9/11,
which we were very affected by.
'Cause we're in the heart
of New Jersey suburbs
of New York City.
I've had the luxury to
navigate two businesses,
Wine Library and VaynerMedia
during the economic crisis.
So the, the exposure of
am I a wartime general?
That's what I,
that's why I've been
talking for the last two
or three years for people
to save their money
and get mentally ready.
Like, I'm more prepared for,
I'm much better at bad
times than good times.
Like I like the punch in the face.
I like the adversity.
I like the fear.
I like the unknown.
I like the challenges.
I like the humility.
I like the step backs.
I like the canceling fun things
to do shit things.
So, it has an exposed.
It it's just reaffirmed something
I've already known about myself.
- Great.
That's awesome to hear.
- Thanks Sarah.
That's all I had.
So I appreciate the time.
Thank you.
Bye.
- Good luck.
- Bye.
- Let's keep going.
Let's keep this shit going.
Dustin.
Jesse, what's--
- Gary, what's up?
Hey, what's up man?
So a little background,
I'm an 18 year old musician
from Massachusetts and,
I'm a senior just graduated 2020 and yeah.
- Congrats, bro.
- And, I empathize with like my peers
and stuff 'cause they lost all their--
- Prom, graduation, all that shit, yep.
- But for me it is,
it's let me figure out
something that like,
like I'm finally free from
the constant comparison
of like that school had,
like I've always felt like I was behind.
I was always not doing
what I needed to do,
but now that that's
eliminated from my life,
I know I want to be a musician.
Like I'm going for it,
I'm going for it like 100% good.
- Good.
- So my question--
- Quick thing, Jesse.
First and foremost, that
comparison game doesn't change
just 'cause you're out of high school.
That comparison game is in perpetuity.
You're about to compare
yourself to everybody
who makes music.
- Yeah and that's kind kinda
what I was saying, but like,
I feel like it's easier
because I know I want to do music
and I, I care less about like it's
because I'm doing what I want to do--
- Instead of what you have to do.
- Instead of being compared to like,
people who are getting eight A's
in chemistry while I'm sitting there
with a C, C minus.
- I got an F in chemistry,
so good shit.
- Okay, thanks.
So, my question is,
this is like I'm working
on my debut stuff.
I got the TikTok roll
and I got 22 or 21,000 on TikTok.
But I want to get my like music debut,
but every time I'm creating,
I'm getting discouraged.
'Cause it's not how I picture in my head.
So my question is like,
how do you save yourself from
that discouragement before
you release something?
- By realizing your opinion
of it actually doesn't matter.
- What do you mean by that?
- Well, we saw Tiago, right?
Did you watch the first interview?
- Yeah.
- He almost didn't post the thing
that changed his music career
because he didn't like it.
- True.
- It's a fucked up kind of point of view.
- Yeah.
Like if you think about it,
it's like, yo, you're like, yo, Gary,
I want to make this music
into the like.
And I'm like, well,
you can't like your own shit or love it
because the market is
actually gonna play it out
and that's fucked up.
And he's like, wait a minute.
Like shouldn't I shouldn't I have today.
And where you end up
realizing it goes is like,
focus on what you're saying
more than your own insecurities,
judging the output.
- I see, all right.
- Where I want your mind is.
Like, did I tell the world what I wanted
to tell them?
Not do as my insecurities take
over when I listened to it,
do I hear it as a hit on my subjective
one person point of view.
- Hmm.
And one other thing is like,
is it better to stay in one genre
and really build up that genre
or try multiple different genres?
- Multiple different genres,
because you're too young.
You don't know if you're a reggae
or hip hop or pop or country.
Like if you even ask that
question, the answer, if one,
even debates that they
must try multiple genres.
Because a lot of artists don't,
a lot of artists like
I'm hip hop, I'm country,
because they have that conviction.
That's amazing, for you,
it's still a debate and you need
to go out and fucking taste.
- Yeah, definitely.
Thank you.
It's just hard to fight that.
Like, that fear.
'Cause TikTok, it's easy to post content.
I'm really good at--
- For now.
- Yeah.
- No, for now.
TikTok's gonna be hard for everybody.
In two years,
Instagram was easy five years ago too.
TikToks about to be hard for everybody
because everyone's going to be there.
It's not the platform.
It's the judgment of the
scale of the community.
TikTok's easy because nobody gave a fuck.
'Cause nobody thought anybody was there.
But in three years,
everyone's gonna struggle
posting on TikTok.
'Cause everyone's gonna be there
and it's gonna fuck everyone up.
Just like it fucks them up on Instagram.
Instagram doesn't fuck you up.
Your insecurity fucked you up.
- So you gotta kind of
be ahead of the game
on like where,
where it's gonna change.
Like the platform is gonna change.
- You need to be ahead of
the game in your fucking head
to not compare yourself
with any other human and give a fuck
about what anybody thinks.
Then you can go to everywhere,
stay everywhere and not give a fuck.
- Absolutely.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- This is not about
running away from judgment.
This is about running into
judgment and getting cozy
as fuck with judgment.
This is not giving a fuck
about Mrs. Harrington,
that fucking chemistry teacher
or your best friend's mom
who thinks that their
son is smarter than you
because they got an A
and you got a C minus.
This is not giving a fuck
about TikTok at scale,
when everyone's on it or
how many Spotify listens
or the A and R God of your life,
or your favorite fucking
artists shitting on your music.
When you DM them,
it's not giving a fuck about anybody.
This is about giving a
fuck about one thing.
What do you want to tell the world?
- Yeah.
- You want to tell the world, bro.
That's what I fucking didn't know,
but like the wine world hated me.
When I came out with Wine Library TV,
social media was a fad
when I started doing business content,
I would never make it
because I always cursed.
I was too old for Musical.ly
and TikTok five years ago.
Everybody's always told me no,
I fucking love no.
I want you to fall in love with no,
fall in love with two things,
brother and your life will be amazing.
What do you want to say?
And loving when people say, no,
you fall in love with
those two things, bro.
Everything gets good.
Everything gets good right now.
You're right now your ingredients
you laid out for me are,
there's a lot of opposite to trends there.
What I love though is I don't feel
that you'll, I feel like
you're so young, so early.
And I feel like, I think,
you can pick up on this.
I think you can rewatch
this five, 10, 15 times
and really build on it.
It's about judgment, bro, judgment.
- Judgment, all right.
Thank you, Gary.
I really appreciate it.
- Does it make sense Jess?
- A little bit?
- Yeah.
Let's stay here for a second.
Like basically, let's
stay here for a second.
It's just about actually not caring
what other people think, it's
literally the polar opposite
of high school.
Bro, I moonwalked through high school
'cause I didn't give a fuck.
I fucking, I looked at peer
pressure like this, like,
fuck you want to give a fuck.
If the hottest girl thinks I'm a dork.
If the coolest job
thinks I'm a door, like,
fuck you show me where you're gonna be
in fucking 30 years.
It's about confidence bro.
- Yeah, it's just hard.
'Cause like for the last four years,
you got so many people telling you like,
but so instead of like feeling bad
about like people telling you that,
like you're not gonna make it.
You're not gonna do well.
- You should love that.
- Should be fire.
- Fire, chips on shoulders.
I love that.
There's no there's, Jesse,
there is no more delicious flavor
in the world for a competitor
than I told you so.
- True.
Yeah, I think--
- When you have the hit and you make it,
the next key,
even though you've created
all that fucking resentment is
to convert that into humility.
- Empathy.
- Mm-hm.
I don't razz on my friends and my parents,
friend's parents and all the people
in business along the way that shit on me
when I've made it,
I am compassionate.
I'm nice to them,
but I promise you their no's got me here.
- Sweet.
Awesome.
- No's are good, bro.
- No's are good.
- No's are great.
Bro, no's are great.
No's are the fucking stones
that build the house.
Yeses catch you off guard.
Your mommy saying that
you're good fucks you up.
You believe it.
- Yeah.
That's actually one thing
I've kind of noticed
is like I'd rather someone
be like brutally honest
with me and tell me
like, oh, this song sucks
then like, oh--
- But let me throw it out.
Let me throw another curve volume.
But then you have to not believe them.
I loved when people said no to me,
but I didn't believe them.
- I see.
- Yeah.
Like when somebody--
- It's about believing
in yourself.
- Correct.
And as a musician,
all you have to do
is did I tell the story
that I wanted to tell?
When people said no to me,
even the fucking best
Howard Schultz, Cubans,
I was like, nah,
I'm better than you.
I'm gonna be better than you.
- Man.
This is--
- So, do you see what I'm,
good, so you see where it's coming from?
Like the no is good.
Cause he'd be like,
yeah, chip on shoulder.
But the key is to not believe them.
Believe the shitty part.
Like take in the shit to build on
and then convert it.
It's like, you have to
be this like machine
you take in the no and like, okay,
I'm gonna take this no.
I'm gonna split the N and the O.
The N, I'm gonna use as a brick
to like build my fucking
empire and the, O,
I'm gonna convert into like,
I'm gonna circle it back at you
and be like, nah, fuck you.
You don't know.
So it's conviction and humility
and patience and adversity
and build and build and build
and then pop up at 32
and have your moment.
- True.
I mean, I'm all for it.
I love the process.
I love making music,
And I'm prepared to live the kind of life
that it will take to succeed.
I'm prepared to,
work in a restaurant,
tables and it's, yeah.
It's probably just--
- Jesse you got to put out music,
Jesse, you gotta put out music.
You gotta put out music, bro.
- That's the one thing I've been lacking.
- Of course 'cause you're
valuing their opinions too much.
You feel like if it doesn't hit
and if it fucking,
it doesn't do well
that it hurts your self-esteem.
I can't have you do that.
That's why I jumped on
the high school thing.
I knew you were in trouble
off your first sentence.
Not in trouble, let me rephrase.
I knew there was opportunity to build here
because you're so young
off your first phrase,
comparisons increase post high school.
- So I gotta be prepared I guess, huh?
- Hell yeah bro.
Do you understand what
happens in four years
when you haven't made it yet?
Everyone's going like,
what are you gonna
actually do with your life
now that this bullshit
music thing didn't work out.
That's what people gonna say to you.
- Yeah, that's what my
parents were saying to me too.
But I've been trying to have
that conversation with them.
Like, this is what I want to do.
I'm prepared to do this,
but it's hard,
but I think I'll be able to manage it.
- I believe you.
- All right, thank you so much, Gary.
I appreciate it, man.
- You're welcome,
talk to you soon.
He is 18.
Wolf's Productions.
All right, that was a good one.
Dustin, there were some gems in there.
- Yeah, I really liked that one a lot.
- Me too, let's get the
team to chop that up
and get it into the testing ASAP.
- Cool.
- Let's keep it going.
- What's up, Gary?
- What's up, Coach J?
- All is good, man.
All is good, I appreciate you.
Bringing beyond right now,
even though somewhere
between yesterday and today,
I lost my wallet
and I'm freaking out,
(Gary chuckles)
but I said to myself, you know what,
A-B-C, adversity builds character.
- I was gonna say.
Did you leave the house?
- Yeah, I went somewhere.
- (laughs) Somewhere.
- I went to the post
office and it was closed
because I totally forgot
yesterday was a holiday here.
I'm in Toronto, Canada,
and it was a holiday
and I got a drink.
I got some snacks and
between the post office,
which is at the local
drug store and my house,
I lost it.
- Wait, if you've got
some drinks and snacks
you paid for that.
- I paid for it.
But yeah, so I don't know if I dropped it
on the way to back to the
car or something who knows.
- You're gonna go back and check, right?
- Yeah, I'll figure it out then man.
Listen, adversity builds character.
- 1,000%.
- I've been listening for
you for some time now.
You helped me through
some darkest moments.
I found you through Evan
Carmichael on his YouTube
and you said some powerful stuff there.
And I just, from that day
on, I just kept following.
I kept following everybody
that's been on the show.
I kept following and just
asking them questions.
And it's interesting because
we're roughly the same age.
I'm 43.
I got two young, two young girls
and this moment is a defining moment.
And like, if I get choked up,
it's because there are kids like myself,
there are parents like myself
that don't know where to turn at times.
And there are moments where you have
to write that goal down.
You got to set steps
in the right direction
and know that you're gonna,
you're gonna get there.
You got to get a lot of nos.
Like you told the young man,
I got a lot of nos because I'm a,
I'm an adult with ADHD and I
did not let that define me.
I'm not letting that define my moment.
- Coach J, it's often the strength.
- It is, but it takes a lot of,
you know, the game in
between the noggin, right?
Like it takes a lot of
willing yourself to want
to get to that next
level and what you have
to do to get there.
So my question to you would be Gary,
is have accomplished a
lot of things in my life
because I took a lot of nos.
And you said, do TikTok
do all these platforms.
I literally told my Instagram following,
which was the big and my clientele
that I'm starting this new new initiative,
which is called Gym Class with Coach J,
it's on your screen there because my,
the goal has to be more
important than the rule.
John C. Maxwell said that,
that my goal in life
has to be more important
than my role as a person.
And I think that's what you're doing.
And if there's kids out
there that think, oh,
I'm never gonna get onto Gary Vee.
This is a kid that took 20 plus years
to get on to Gary Vee right now.
And I'm doing it.
Honestly, Gary, I'm doing it for them.
I'm doing it for all the parents
that don't know where to turn,
where their kids are getting
into trouble or getting
into drugs and stuff like that because I'm
on a mission Gary with,
or without you, Gary,
make sure you do your pushups today,
by the way
- I will, I promise.
- Every day.
- I promise.
- Yeah.
I tell Dustin every day I ask him,
I message him every day.
Say, make sure you do your
workouts and my messages too.
There are a lot of people
that are gonna be in COVID
and we're in complete lockdown right now
that don't have an outlet
and the gym is outlet.
Gary, I've been in by myself
in this gym, no members,
nobody by myself for 10 weeks.
And I've been doing
things online and trying
to get the message out there.
My question, I wrote it down,
where do I take my
business that has no money
into something special
that has mass impact?
- Well, it's just execution.
I mean, like, you'll appreciate this.
It's step by step.
Like first, you've got to
figure out how to monetize
so that you can be self-efficient.
So that if you don't build
a foundation financially,
that allows you to do it in perpetuity,
it's gonna be hard to have the kind
of impact that I think
you've created in your mind,
and/or you realize that
impact doesn't need a physical
or financial execution,
impact can actually be done for free
on things called the internet
on things called social networks.
So it really depends on
how you want to define it.
I'm making mass impact
being Gary Vee and it's a,
not a monetized bubble event for me.
I have my other Gary Vaynerchuk life
where I run my businesses
and I don't have an institute.
I don't have an island.
I don't have a course,
I don't have any structure around it.
What I have is my thoughts
and my aspirations to leave
a humanity footprint as
I'm calling it in my mind
the last 24 hours,
and that is happening
on a daily basis across every platform,
because I'm passionate
about leaving that impact
more so than taking that
impact and turning it
into a monetized old bill event.
On the flip side, it's very okay to
turn it into a monetizeable event.
So this is true.
Sometimes I dream about
like, you know what,
I'm gonna just buy a
fucking mountain somewhere
and carve into the fucking
mountain and be like
this Yoda character and like
people are just gonna come.
And I'm just gonna chill in there
and do Tea with Gary Vee
fucking mountain style.
And that's my business.
That's gonna actually,
I'm not gonna do it for free.
It's gonna be business.
And other times I think it's,
I'm gonna do it for free.
What I'm saying, why I'm
telling you that story,
'cause it's run through
my mind in that way
is it's okay to turn it into a business.
You just have to realize,
are you in it for the impact
or are you in it for the
financial ramifications,
or is it both?
All of it's all good.
But to answer your question, Coach J,
you gotta go up a step higher and say,
if you want to make a global impact,
like you said, well, then,
the reality is you don't need it to be
in the form of a financial
success execution.
You can just do it through
the words and your passion,
on the flip side, you easily can,
I think the way you do that
is you start creating as
much brand as possible
and create a virtual ecosystem.
So it's not just limited
to the Toronto area.
Both Mike Biconti and Jordan Sighet,
both my trainers have made significant
money training people virtually,
doing meal plans and
doing virtual workouts.
Today at 6:30 I'll do a
virtual workout with Mike.
I like how you said do your pushups,
today I canceled this morning,
'cause I felt a little like
lethargic, which is rare,
but I knew it was a leg day.
- Hey, hey, actually, Sarah
in our chat group today was leg day too,
today's shoulders and
Allison conditioning for us.
- So leg day is a beast.
So I wanted to have more
energy and have more strength.
'Cause those fucking Bulgarian
split squats fuck me up.
So, I pushed it to the afternoon,
but nonetheless brother,
I think it's virtual selling.
I think that gives you scale.
- Okay, my last thing, Gary,
and I really appreciate
you taking my call,
is that I just want that message to go out
to anybody that is watching this,
that you guys have to set goals.
Because if I didn't set that goal,
when I was 20, 23, 33 and now 43,
this wouldn't be possible.
You got to set goals.
You gotta believe in yourself.
You got to take a lot of notes.
- The second part.
The second part.
The set goals, I'm with you.
It's the belief when people set goals,
but they don't believe
they're gonna achieve them.
And then they become jails.
I'm gonna be a famous singer,
but they don't actually believe it.
And then it becomes a convoluted,
Coach J, a lot of people
have real bad relationships
with their goals because
of the second part.
It's about actually not
only believing in yourself,
it's actually like a little tweak.
It's accepting yourself and it's not an,
and an accepting yourself.
There's a key other component.
Don't put other people on pedestals.
I watch all these young girls
look at like very pretty girls
on Instagram and put them on pedestals.
And everybody's got
different bone structure
and different like the day
we were all born different,
like you're not gonna necessarily be able
to achieve certain things
because of like what
God gave you and that,
but on the flip side, you're fucking,
you have the potential to be one
of the great poets of all time.
But because you want to be like a hot one
on fucking, on TikTok,
you like suppress your
actually what you've been given
because you put somebody
else on a pedestal
because you're actually insecure.
And you're looking for validation
from E boys on TikTok,
it's just fucked up, right?
We need one, setting goals is imperative.
I love that.
I'm with you, but we need to
build an entire generation
of self-esteem building, of acceptance.
Like God, there's so many
things I wish I was better at,
but that was even a difficult
sentence for me to deploy
because I've tuned out that feeling
since I was like fucking 10.
- Right, right.
- Wishing means shit.
Like so like yes goals,
but let's have nice
relationships with goals,
which goes back to a bigger perspective,
which is fucking like,
there's nobody on earth like you.
And if you actually
take that as a positive
and really try to figure out
what the fuck you got, real shit happens.
- 100%.
- Notice how you and I took AHDH,
and I can't even say it.
- ADHD.
- ADHD, like I just know it's a gift,
but if your parents and your teachers
and doctors and society tell you,
it's a stigma,
you become insecure,
- 100%.
- But if you're told it's fucking amazing,
look at who's that supermodel,
who's got the skin condition, right.
You know what I'm talking about?
- I'm not too sure.
- So there's a supermodel,
she's got a skin condition
where she's like,
got like patches, like, super famous.
I'm just like, I don't pay
attention to that world.
But like, I know if I saw her,
somebody just put her name in here.
I think I saw, like--
- Winnie Harlow.
- That's right.
So that look could have been
considered not beautiful,
but she in her inner
soul made it beautiful.
Now the world thinks it's beautiful.
Look what's considered good looking now.
When I was growing up Kate Moss,
when I was a teenager,
you had to look like Kate Moss to be hot.
Like that is not the look now.
- No.
- And so like, things change,
but like what doesn't change
is you loving yourself
or are you hating yourself?
I just want to get everybody
to love themselves period.
End of story.
Because the second they do,
they start leaning into weird shit.
Nerd culture, are you kidding me?
We're the same age, right?
You weren't allowed to like comic books
and fucking Pokemon and nerd shit.
Now the fucking coolest hip
hop artists in the world
rock fucking Dragon Ball Z shit.
Like are you fucking kidding me?
- Making millions off of it now.
Making millions, right?
So, Hey Gary, man, listen,
there's a whole bunch of guests
that need to hear their voice
and I want them to get their time.
I appreciate it.
If you come to Toronto,
man, hit me up for a workout.
- I will, brother.
- Hey, start following me, man.
So I can send you these workouts
and much love to you, man.
And all the kids out
there, all the parents,
keep fighting the good fight, man.
Gym Class with Coach J, I'm your guy.
And peace out from Coach J, man.
- Peace out, Coach J.
- All right, Gary.
- Gym Class Heroes, I miss them.
All right Coach J, you got the follow
on your 131st follow, watch this.
Throw it back up.
Throw it back up, Dustin,
let's do a follow storm.
Everybody in the Vayner nation
watching Tea with GaryVee,
let's do a follow storm.
Let's fucking make.
I think we all can agree
that Coach J is a sweet soul.
Let's just take one minute right now.
Even if you're watching me on a phone,
you can step away for a second.
Let's do a massive follow storm.
Let's do a follow bomb,
whatever we're gonna call it.
Let's just blitz him.
Let's blitz him, he's up to 154.
I expect to check this in a second
and I expect us to be at 700.
Let's blow this guy away.
Let's make him super happy.
He's worth it.
He's a good dude.
Let's keep it going.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey, Shea.
- Hey, thank you so much.
- How are you?
- Good, good, thank you.
And thank you,
Zane and Dustin in the
background for doing all of this.
Also I do want to just say
Coach J is the sweetest
because he did, he followed everyone
who's been in our little
private chat back here.
I went to go follow him and
he was already following me.
So everyone should take your advice,
but yes, basically I'm an actor.
That's my greatest skill.
That's the main goal is to make
that a full-time thing for me.
But I, to my own surprise have found
some success doing
political comedy videos,
especially on TikTok,
which thank you a hundred
percent because of you
that I got on that platform.
I did not expect for political comedy
to do well there,
but it's done, I'm not--
- Everything will do well
there, Shea, for anybody
who's watching right now
who doesn't think their
thing works on TikTok,
TikTok is a mass platform.
Everything works on there.
- It totally is.
And I mean, I see it with everyone
that I've become friends
with through doing it
and how it's changed their lives.
it's my favorite platform,
which kind of comes to my question,
because of the success that I've had.
And also my greatest skill is not writing.
I can, I'm a great actor,
but I've found that political comedy
helps me put a bubble around it
and focus as a writer
so I can create my own content.
So I've felt as if that's a good way
into the industry for me,
that I can wiggle my way in
and make acting a full-time job that way.
And it's done well for me on TikTok until,
it also attracts fairly aggressive trolls,
which I'm fine with,
except for in about a
month and a half ago,
I had one of them report me one time
on a livestream for dangerous behavior.
And I got my live streaming
banned permanently,
which I haven't been able to get ahold
of anyone at TikTok to fix yet.
- Send me an email,
I'll help you.
- Really, oh my gosh.
- Yeah, on my VaynerMedia team
who's got relationships with the platform
and see if they can help.
- I would so appreciate that.
That was my main thing is I
was really depending on it.
- But Shea, you need to be in the mindset
of if you lost live
stream on TikTok forever,
that that's a minor event.
- Yeah, well that's my question.
- Stick with me on this though.
- Yeah.
- I really want to spend a second on that.
Like then just make TikTok videos
to send everybody to you on Instagram.
Like, do you see what I mean?
I never want you to be at
the mercy of the platform.
- Yeah, exactly.
That was my biggest fear
is that I was really
depending on it a lot.
I've started, I've made videos,
pushing people to come to my Instagram.
It's more of a fact of...
- YouTube, Twitter.
- Yes, YouTube and making--
- Are you on Twitter?
- I am on Twitter.
I'm on all the platforms
@sheadepmore everywhere.
The amount of time that it takes me
to make a political comedy
video that I'm happy with,
and that's relative,
I make a lot of silly ones on TikTok
just to post for the day sometimes.
But the amount of time
it takes me, I'm still,
I'm doing one a day on TikTok.
I'm trying to figure out
how to basically diversify
and grow from here,
given that I assumed--
- By eliminating your,
the part of your sentence
that says that I'm happy on.
- Yeah.
And just making it.
- You gotta make more.
- Yeah.
Yeah, no that's a hundred percent.
- What happens is somebody figures out.
So for on TikTok right now
is a lot of people are
winning in my community.
'Cause obviously I was an early advocate
and people are finally starting
to kind of like figure it out.
The thing I fear is they're
gonna have a single TikTok
that does well when they're testing.
And then all their TikToks look like that
because they're trying to
recreate the viral moment.
- Yeah.
- When you have something hit,
you've got to do that.
But then you got to
keep constantly testing.
Like it's almost like
you've got to make one,
one video that you like,
and you've got to make one video
for your old peril, Gary, every day.
That's completely different.
- Yeah.
Huh.
Do you think that--
- If you're an actor as an actress,
you should be making some
sort of unique TikTok,
that's not political every time.
I think your following,
won't be upset if you
have one that's political
and one that's just silly on trend
or one where you're acting
something that's happening.
- Yeah, that was my question is just,
do you think it can grow past there
or does it need to kind
of niche down, but.
- Grow.
- Yay, okay.
Awesome, I'm so excited,
I remember yesterday you were
talking to the filmmaker,
the kid that was just out of film school
that you were gonna want to try
and do films down the road.
So I'm gonna keep an eye out for that.
I'm very excited.
- It's gonna happen one day.
So keep an eye out.
- Yeah, do it.
All right, thank you so much, okay, bye.
- Looks like Coach J got lit on, huh?
Let's see.
I love this community.
All right, what's going on.
- Gary Vee!
- What's good, fam?
- How you doing brother?
- Well what's your name?
- I can't believe this is
real, my name is Koran.
- Where you from?
- I'm from Los Angeles.
I just want to say how appreciative I am
for your consistent content man.
Like ever since I graduated college,
it's just kept me on the perfect balance
between motivated and grateful.
So I just want to thank you for that.
Quick background basically I graduated
two years ago from UCI
and ever since I've had
this topic on my mind
that I've been really passionate about
and it's one you advocate a lot too.
So I got myself to finally
write a book on it,
which is something I didn't
want to do for a while.
And the topic is basically
on why you don't necessarily need college
to be successful depending
on where you're at
and your position in life.
And I just like touch
upon all the subjects
that you go on to,
why we don't need, it's
not the same thing,
'cause we have our phones
in our pocket all the time.
We could just Google this information.
I have an entire chapter that
I like dedicated basically
to you on the four year vacation.
So I was really happy
to talk to you about it.
And basically my question to you today is,
I just finished writing it like a week
or two ago and I'm in the editing phase
and I want to see what you'd recommend
in terms of maximizing my exposure
when I'm finally ready to release it.
In terms of like advertising,
social media, word of mouth,
where you say to double down on all that?
- I would start putting out
as much content as possible
on TikTok four a day of the
themes that are in the book.
'Cause that's a great audience for you.
'Cause it's young and
it's the one platform
where you can catch virality right now
as a nobody on social media.
- Now what type of content would you say?
Just like me, like recording myself,
talking about my ideas or?
- Yep.
- Okay.
I was definitely ready for
you to hit me with a TikTok.
'Cause I know that's
something I didn't mind.
- Look, if you're talking about a book
that says you don't need
college, TikTok's amazing.
'Cause you've got kids in
there in that age group
and you've got parents
now on there with kids
in that age group.
- True.
- It's your best platform.
And what's funny about Tea with GaryVee
and TikTok is it's no different than the
Ask Gary Vee Show in Instagram.
Years ago when I was doing
the Ask Gary Vee Show,
a lot of the answers were Instagram.
Tea with Gary Vee a lot
of the answers are TikTok.
It's because attention arbitrage,
like you're asking me
how to market your book.
It's attention.
If I told you influential marketing
and send everybody every
influencer of your book,
you're hoping that they
post it on their Instagram
and it's tagged and goes.
If I told you to do a podcast,
you hope the podcast does well
and people buy your book.
It's all just one game.
The game is so simple.
It's just attention.
And right now the under-priced attention,
the opportunity to garner
attention is TikTok.
I don't give a fuck about TikTok,
if fuckin' TikTok disappeared tomorrow,
I'd give zero fucks.
Could care fucking less,
Have no investment in Bike
dance, could care less.
Like not scared of losing
my 3.7 million followers
on the platform, could give a fuck.
- Just make the best
of it while it's there.
- A hundred percent,
a hundred percent.
Got it?
- Yeah, anything else in terms of like--
- No.
- Other stuff?
Just throw it down on TikTok,
that's the biggest thing.
- Four a day.
And of course talk your thoughts.
Talk about the four year vacation,
but how are you gonna make that video
about the four year vacation?
Is it gonna be just you straight talking
and a mundane thing?
Or are you gonna take a song
that's trending and then
do some sticker overlays
and then put a gif.
Like you gotta be creative
to the best of your
ability in that platform.
Maybe you do duets.
Maybe you look for people
talking about college
and you do duets.
Like you gotta fucking create.
And your ability creating that platform
contextually is gonna be the
valuable of your success.
- Gotcha.
I've been like just going through
the different social medias,
seeing where I should like double down
on thinking if I should
do like little of each
or like going more on one--
- TikTok.
- But I will definitely take that advice
and start getting in on TikTok
and just wanted to see if
you had any other like things
I could add to my book.
'Cause I know you're big on it.
- Nope.
You've taken plenty of thought
starters from me, right?
Write what you believe.
- Is there any way you can take
a look at my book or
something when it's done?
I know you get a lot but I'd love you to.
- I would, listen,
I don't want to bullshit you
like books are my kryptonite.
- Yeah, I've heard you talk about it.
- I don't even like my
own five best sellers.
- I love it.
- Thank you brother.
But I wish you nothing but the best.
- I appreciate that, Gary Vee.
You're amazing.
You have a good one.
- Thank you, you too, bro.
Alright, Dustin, good show.
I like that.
Nice and solid came out hard.
8:45, 9:45.
And they still have time slot
a little early for some people.
Some people missed it.
- Yeah.
- That there's 15.
Coach J.
Life just got flipped upside down.
You know he's happy as fuck.
- Definitely.
- Big wine taste day,
debating between a white and a rose.
Both under 20 bucks.
People have been yelling at me.
They need some under $20 wine.
So coming at that today,
If you haven't signed
up for Wine Texts yet
and you buy wine on the internet
or at all, you're terrible human,
you've broken my heart
and I don't like you anymore.
(Dustin chuckling)
Also excited about my new Twitter account.
GaryVeeTV, Gary V-E-E-T-V.
I highly, I mean,
if a thousand people
went and just followed
Coach Jay on Instagram,
I highly recommend you
go to Twitter right now
and follow this account.
We're about to go super ham on it.
If you want to know more about it,
here is the 411.
And the people that are gonna win
over the next five to seven years
are gonna be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
You don't love the process.
This is dreams we're talking about.
Dreams require sacrifice.
All of your actions
have to then map to it.
Backpack, backpack, backpack.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work.
It's being respectful.
It's being a good person.
Do that, that's just a good idea.
It's there, the flip game is there.
This house right here, there's $400 in it.
I stay in my lane like real fucking tight.
But you can't be crippled.
Everybody here is judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing 'cause
you're laying in your bed,
looking at somebody's fucking
glamorous photoshopped picture
of them doing something cool.
And you're envious and you're jealous
and you're impatient.
And it's crippling your upside.
Let me just say it one more time.
if you're confused what I just said.
I say, put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five-year window of your life.
My only answer to Nate
or anybody like it's just like, try shit.
Put your business down
and go work for an apparel
company for 20 years.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you've got to get your speed up.
You better work harder.
You better work smarter.
If you can't Google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
Gary V-E-E TV, my new account.
Check me out, hope you enjoy it.
(upbeat music)